let's do some more practice word
problems Patricia is building a sandbox
for her daughter it is to be five feet
wide and 8 feet long so let me draw that
so the five feet wide it is to be five
feet wide so there you go that's five
feet right there and eight feet long
other than an orange eight feet long so
this is like if we're looking down on
the sandbox eight feet long eight feet
long so the sandbox if we're looking
down on it would look something like
that that would be five feet and then
this side over here would also be eight
feet all right she wants the height of
the sandbox to be four inches above the
height of the sand okay so if we were to
draw the sandbox like this so if we were
to draw it in draw three so that's eight
that is that distance right there is
five feet and then there is some height
which I think we're going to have to
figure out let me draw the whole box
just like that and just like that the
sand is going to fill a certain amount
of the sandbox so the sand is going to
fill maybe until right over there so
that's how much the sand is going to
fill of the sandbox so all of that is
sand and she wants the height of the
sandbox to be four inches above the
height of the sand so she wants this
distance right here the amount that the
height goes above the sand itself to be
four four inches or a third of a foot
depending how you want to think about it
now she has 30 cubic feet of sand she
has 30 cubic feet of sand so this sand
right here is 30 feet cubed how high
should the sandbox be so this
information right here the volume of the
sand tells us we using it we can figure
out how high the level of the sand will
be because the let's view it this way
let's call let's call L let's call L or
we gonna choose X let's say X is the
height of the sand
X is equal to height of sand so the
total volume of our sand is going to be
the height of the sand times the length
of the box times 8 times the width of
the box times 5 and this is going to be
the total volume which they told us is
30 cubic feet it is 30 cubic feet we're
taking X feet times 8 feet times 5 feet
so we'll get 30 feet cubed if we were to
keep track of the units so what is this
8 times 5 is 40 8 times 5 is 40 so we
get 40 X is equal to 30 if we divide
both sides by 40 both sides of the
equation by 40 let me do that you divide
both sides by 40 you get X is equal to
that just becomes an X X is equal to 30
over 40 where it equals 3
it equals 3/4 of a foot so this right
here this right here is going to be 3/4
of a foot now what is 3/4 of a foot we
know let's see 3/4 of a foot we know
that there are we know that there are 12
inches per foot the feet cancel out 12
times 3 over 4 is what you can divide 12
by 4 and get a 3 divide the 4 by 4 you
get a 1 you get 3 by 2 times 3 this is 9
inches 9 inches so the height of the
sand right there is 9 inches now she
wants the height of the sandbox to be 4
inches above the height of the sand so
this is 9 inches she wants four more
inches so what she wants the height of
the sandbox height of sandbox it should
be the 9 inches of the height of the
sand plus 4 which is equal to 13 inches
and we are done let's do the next
problem it was a sale day in Macy's and
everything was 20% less than the regular
price Peter bought a pair of shoes and
two using a coupon
got an additional he got an additional
10 per centimeter than a different color
he got an additional ten percent off the
discounted price the price he paid was
$36 the price he paid for the shoes and
do that in a different color the price
he paid for the shoes was $36 how much
did it originally cost so let's just use
so X is equal to original original cost
so there was just a regular sale on that
day everything was 20% less than the
regular price
so using that information on that day if
you want to buy the shoes the cost of
the shoes would be X minus 0.2 Oh X or
0.2 Oh which is equal to 0.8 X right if
you have 20% off of a price you're going
to be paying eighty percent of the
original price so this is the price that
everyone would have paid without a
coupon and that's what that line is
telling us right there
now Peter got a pair of shoes and using
a coupon got an additional 10% off of
this an additional 10% off of that so
he's paying 10% less than this or
another way to think of it is he only
had to pay 90% of this price right if
you take if you take 0.8 X and from that
you subtract 10% of this so from that
you subtract 10 percent of that of 0.8 X
alright this is the same thing right
this is 1 times 0.8 X this is the same
thing as 1 minus 0.1 so this is the same
thing this is equal to 90% of 0.8 X of
0.8 X and it might actually be very
natural for you to go straight to this
it's natural for me if I paying 20% less
than the regular price that means I'm
going to pay 80% of the regular price
and if I get an additional 10% off of
that that means I'm only going to pay
90% of that so this is what he
is going to pay and we they tell us that
that price is $36 that price is equal to
$36 so if we want to figure out X well
we can multiply 0.9 times 0.8 let's do
that
so 0.9 times 0.8 9 times 8 is 72 we have
two numbers behind the decimal one two
so it's 0.72 so you get 0.72 X is equal
to 36 or maybe we could say 72 over a
hundred 72 over 100 X is equal to 36 or
we could even say this is the same thing
as what is that that's the same thing as
36 over 50 right 36 over 50 X is equal
to 36 and this isn't even in lowest
common forms I could keep if I could
this is the same thing as 18 over 25 but
I like this number because it I have a
36 here and so I can multiply both sides
by the inverse of this 50 over 36 times
this I have to do it to both sides of
the equation 50 over 36 36 is canceled
out 50 s cancel out 36 is canceled out
and you're left with X is equal to $50
the shoes originally cost $50 next
question
Rosa has saved all year and wishes to
spend the money she has on new clothes
and a vacation she will spend 30 percent
more on the vacation than on the clothes
so let's say let's see that C is amount
spent on clothes she's going to spend 30
percent more on the vacation so let's
say V is equal to the amount spent on
vacation well they just told us that the
vacation she's going to spend 30 percent
more than on the clothes
so the vacation is going to be equal to
the amount she spends on the clothes
plus 30 percent of the amount she spends
on
clothes and this is the same thing as
1.3 1.3 times the amount she spends on
the clothes that's how much she's going
to spend on the vacation now if she
saved a thousand in total how much money
to the nearest whole dollar can she
spend on the vacation so between V and C
she can only spend a thousand dollars so
V vacation plus her clothes can only be
one thousand dollars and so we know what
the vacation is in terms of the clothes
we can do a little substitution the
vacation is going to be one point three
times the clothes so we can substitute
there so you have one point three times
the clothes that's the vacation
expenditure plus the amount she spends
on the clothes is equal to one thousand
this is one point three plus one is two
point three times the amount of clothes
is automatic spends on clothes will be
equal to one thousand dollars divide
both sides by two point three I'll get
the calculator out for this one so we
have one thousand divided by two point
three is equal to four hundred thirty
four dollars and seventy eight cents so
C is equal to I already forgot the
number 434 78 434 and seventy eight
dollars so that's the amount she spends
on clothes the rest of her money is
going to be spent on a vacation so her
vacation is going to be at one thousand
minus this so her vacation expenditure
is going to be one thousand minus four
hundred thirty-four point seven eight
under the calculator for this one so
let's see let's make this into a
negative number and then let's add one
thousand to it and we get five hundred
and sixty five dollars and 22 cents so
five hundred and sixty five dollars and
22 cents and I'll leave it up to you to
check it this this is how much she
spends on the vacation these add up to a
thousand dollars and this should be
exactly thirty percent more than this
amount the amount she spends on her
clothes